die lust
[Musik]
ja
mit einer frau an der spitze will sich
die spd erneuern wir finden dann muss
auch eine neue hymne her
ich mache jetzt mal ein paar vorschläge
und zwar zusammen mit der heute show
band training hast du bock und los
geht's an der macht zu sein schreiben
adels in den saal hinein du und ich
stimmen ein
[Musik]
und zwar geht es um die hymne wann wir
schreiten seit an seit die ist ja jetzt
nicht mehr ganz so frischen was soll das
denn jetzt
was jetzt konkret parteitag
ja ja hier ist keine diskussion über 100
sondern ja aber die spd will sich
erneuern und das ist ja teil auch der
noch nichts zu tun was jahrzehnte für zu
euch da ich die stimmung sowie ist sehr
gut sehr positiv auf den patrick buck
mal wiederholen
[Musik]
wunder gibt es immer wieder außer bei
den süden können sie geschehen bei uns
können sie geschehen finden sich so gut
dass eine frau vorsitzende wird nicht
weil alles ist ja letztendlich weiblich
was die spd ausmacht oder es ist alles
weiblich die sozialdemokratie die
niederlage die scham die schande
der erfolg genau das ist eben nicht
weiter
natürlich nicht türlich war amtlich
braucht dich natürlich natürlich doch
verdammt ich will dich natürlich nicht
natürlich habe es ausprobiert also dass
also diese zwischen einsätze haben wir
jetzt nicht gefallen muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen wir haben sehr gut
gefallen man kann es gar nicht oft genug
probieren und die spd gibt man nicht auf
schönen sie gar nicht so viel zeit für
sie weil ich muss den parteitag eröffnen
und wegen ihnen kann ich jetzt auch
nicht zu spät machen gerne beim nächsten
mal noch einmal
der wahltag ist jetzt erstmal nicht so
wichtig ich habe ein paar songs
vorbereitet um die hymne zu erneuern und
ich sage ihnen mal einen vorschlag vor
andrea nahles sowie in der eifel geboren
simone lange hat schon verloren weil sie
wirklich keine sarault cams keine ahnung
hat zugleich
weiß auch er dass auch meine letzte zu
verbrannt werden
die verbrannte verbleiben ihn nicht also
da hingerichtet wie dabei verschiedene
ausdrücken kann sich besser durchsetzen
als männer
jaja glaube schon dass privat bei ihnen
meine frau ich meinen psychologen mit
fragt meine frau immer fragt der arzt
habe
haben sie probleme mit fühlen sie sich
von ihrem mann als ich die zutaten und
die basis gemacht das war schon da haben
wir noch was ja ich habe noch acht
anderen sieben anderen noch 4000 mal
regiert 1000 passiert 1000 mal an der
macht es hat alles nichts gebracht aber
auch selbstkritik nicht drastisch ab
montag 6 in finnland schon nach uns hat
nichts gebracht hat dazu merkt kann ich
da irgendwas tun ja vielleicht mal sind
total hässlichen spot über merkel
so zwingen lassen in der coaching dass
merkel singt dann geht es auch mit uns
[Musik]
und damit zurück ins studio
[Applaus]